let's derive the formulas for the  difference and sum of cubes  geometrically let's say you have one  cube with volume X cubed and another  cube with volume y cubed the difference  in volumes of these cubes is equal to X  cubed minus y cubed  but we can also calculate the volume as  the sum of the volumes of three  different cuboids  it is easy enough to calculate the  dimensions of each of these cuboids  we then multiply these Dimensions  together to get the volume of each of  these cuboids  we sum these volumes together and then  we take out the factor of x minus y to  get the formula for the difference of  Cubes  now we simply substitute Y is equal to  negative Z and like a buy one get one  free coupon we get the formula for the  sum of cubes and that's the formula for  the difference and sum of cubes